you can help a be
go oh no my feet got stuck help push me
push my feet got stuck they're
stuck oh there they
go
push you got Stu again
push push push they got stuck oh
oh
no
again push hard hard push
hard who there they
go back again oh no the lava the la
la
again push
push wow oh my hand went down you got it
here we go
go
go go get
sensei
[Music]
okay my fear St again
push
push push
good push
push push push push
push
good what what are they doing I can't
see oh no the lava why a't she getting
Sensei the lava go get Sensei get him
get turn turn turn help here we go turn
turn turn turn turn turn turn turn
turn turn more good turn turn turn turn
turn turn yes turn turn turn turn turn
good there we go your hands use your
hands
good good faster Tristan here he comes
faster AB be turn and use your hands
good I can't see I can't see good
good
good okay you get him Abby run at
him
fast use your
hands
run use your hands
sir
good who use your hands and knock his
hands out of the
way start closer s not so far right
there go
don't run around her run into her push
her if she doesn't do it push her if she
doesn't do
it
yes
no there you
go good oh now
turn
yes
turn who got you use your
hands good there you go oh good
girl oh
got you here we
[Music]
go
yes
yes yes
good if you rest they
[Music]
rest get opposite
him change
levels
get opposite
[Music]
him come on sarf pull it
down just grab it pull it
down come on you have to work look for
work look for work go go
go
good try good try that was good try
again try
again good
work try try
Rion
you have to pull it down you can't just
hit
it come on work work work work he looks
tired my God come on Rion
go go get
him good work
spruha work work let's go spra let's
go good work work work work work work
work work he looks tired he looks
tired rest stay opposite him spruha stay
opposite him on the Square opposite him
there you
go opposite
him opposite
him come on tra tighter Corner tighter
Corner
oh
awareness awareness don't get stuck on
the target part don't get stuck on the
target go go 10 seconds everyone's
working 10 9 8 7 6 you got a run part
I'll start it over five four he dropped
it run three two one water break water
break